i'm just so grateful the lord gave me
that that that
final time kathie lee gifford opening up
about the last time she saw her former
co-host and longtime
friend regis philbin the 66 year old tv
personality talked about her final
moments with regis
on the today show on monday revealing
that she actually had lunch with him
and his wife joy at her connecticut home
just a few weeks earlier
when i talked to joy she said kathy he
hadn't laughed in a long long time
she said i was so worried about him and
she said and the day that we came to
have lunch with you she said
was the last time i heard him laugh so
well that's just that will forever be
a precious gift the lord gave me that i
got to laugh again with one of my best
friends of
all my lifetime regis who died on friday
at the age of 88
made millions of people laugh alongside
kathie lee when they co-hosted
live with regis and kathy lee from 1985
until 2000.
i just did it every day you know the two
were known for their unscripted combos
and off-the-cuff comedy
we didn't want writers we didn't want a
million producers we didn't want it over
produced we just wanted to sit there and
have fun together
and kathy lee said they built a deep
friendship over the years
he was an entertainer in his guts and so
was i
and so when we came together although we
didn't have a friendship yet
we had a mutual respect for what we had
accomplished already in in our in
our careers and we had the same sense of
humor
and and i wasn't afraid of him and he
sure as heck was not afraid of me and we
just took off like a rocket but before
that today show
tribute kathie lee honored her late
friend on instagram
posting this pic and writing in part
quote i simply adored him and
every day with him was a gift can't
believe you're still even speaking to me
now that you've saved the network and
everything
so important but nevertheless that for
15 years i finally believe
you i don't forget my old friends but
the former daytime talk show host wasn't
the only celeb to pay their respects to
the tv icon
you know as people get older
you you know you always know that some
certain things are inevitable and um
passing away is one of those things but
regis is one of the people that we all
believed
i think would somehow
figure out a way around the inevitable
kelly ripa who co-hosted live with regis
from 2001 to 2011
and continues to host the show with ryan
seacrest opened up about the tv legend
on live
monday so many people reached out to me
and said you're the first person i
thought of you're the first person i
thought of
and which was very comforting
uh but i have to tell you the first
person i thought of was joy and
and joanna and jj his daughters i
thought of the girls you know
and then i thought of kathie lee
and those were i always say like regis
core four
right kelly also paid her respects on
instagram writing that
regis was the ultimate class act adding
that she was beyond lucky to have him as
a mentor
i got presents today from regis
[Laughter]
jimmy kimmel tweeted that the late talk
show host was a good friend
and a tremendous amount of fun maria
shriver said he was
always up always genuine always real
while chris harrison called regis a
legend and a true gentleman
other stars like william shatner josh
gad hoda kotb
billy eichner george sakai ross matthews
holly robinson p
and more shared their love for reach too
is there anything you wish you could do
over
in your life any do-overs
any words of wisdom for people out there
no not really not really no i really
can't think of anything
i think i was very good with with kathy
lee with kelly
um thank god i had them
and that's all i can tell you um
but you know when you come on the show
at nine o'clock
i would always make sure that i did
something the night before
i'd go somewhere go do something see a
movie whatever it was
so that i would have something to talk
about and have fun with
you